bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors une réaction après
l'adoption de cette loi de programmation
la compréhension encore une fois de la
précipitation de la majorité de vouloir
absolument faire un passage en force de
cette loi tant décrié non seulement par
les syndicats mais pas l'ensemble du
monde de la recherche qui ne comprend
pas cette volonté d'aller si vite et
sans concertation finalement la seule
concertation qu'il y a eu c'était avec
les présidents d'universités qui sont
les rares gagnants de la réforme
mais pour ce qui est des vacataires des
précaires des chercheurs et des autres
l'intérêt de cette réforme reste à voir
tel est bâclée à tel point que même un
député de la majorité qui connaît bien
le monde de la recherche cédric villani
a préféré voter contre tente cette
réforme ne faisait pas honneur au
travail qui avait été fait en amont par
rapport au constat juste de la
revalorisation nécessaire des métiers
des filières de la recherche
alors vous dites cette réforme est
bâclée mais qu'est ce qu'on lui reproche
précisément quels sont ses défauts
alors on lui reproche d'être d'abord une
réforme en trompe-l'oeil uniquement là
pour faire semblant comme beaucoup de
réformes actuellement donc communiquer
sur le fait que le budget augmente alors
qu'en réalité le fait que ce budget soit
sur un si long terme comme vous le
disiez 10 ans ne permet pas de voir
réellement commencé milliards injectés
dans la recherche vont réellement être
utile parce qu'on parle de 15 à 20
milliards de passer de 15 à 20 milliards
de par an à par paliers de 25 milliards
mais sur dix ans ça paraît être une
dissolution finalement de l'effort
ça c'est la première critique qui ai
fait la deuxième critique et elle est de
taille c'est sur le délit d' entrave
là il ya une loi qui fait que
l'occupation des universités serez punis
maintenant de trois ans d'emprisonnement
et 45000 euros damende donc vous voyez
on passe l'article 24 aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale et là encore une
mesure liberticide dans une loi portée
par la majorité
ça commence à faire beaucoup et c'est
extrêmement inquiétant parce que les
universités sont le lieu de la création
de la recherche mais aussi de la
contestation
on n'aurait pas eu sans doute mai 68 sur
les universités on n'aurait pas eu
l'école de pensée française si
l'université n'était pas un
contre-pouvoir un lieu de la pensée
contestataires avec des gens comme
derrida comme foucault ou comme d'autres
qui ont été capables de porter cette
cette vision française du monde donc on
est en train de saboter d'une certaine
façon c'est paul de liberté que sont les
universités
et puis l'aggravation de la concurrence
entre les laboratoires puisque ce serait
maintenant des fonds qui arriverait par
projet donc les laboratoires vont sans
doute privilégié des recherches qui vont
rapporter donc la logique financière la
logique de profit qui rentre dans la
recherche là où elle ne devrait pas être
puisque il est normal que dans la
recherche appliquée on cherche là où il
n'y a pas forcément d'argent à se faire
mais simplement parce que c'est utile de
chercher sans chercher à faire de
l'argent dans la logique macro nist il
faut faire de l'argent avec tous la
santé et la recherche
en l'occurrence en l'occurrence donc ça
fait beaucoup et comme d'habitude les
réponses du gouvernement et de la
ministre ont été vous n'avez pas compris
cette réforme toujours trop de subtilité
trop d'intelligences et y aura des
concertations
une fois que cette réforme sera votée
quel est l'intérêt pourquoi aller si
vite et c'est bien là où est le loup et
qui le fait que les syndicats de
chercheurs les chercheurs et
l'opposition condamne et critiquent
cette réforme parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
de concertation comme d'habitude à
l'excès poulain ce qu'il existe des
recours face à cette réforme quelle est
la suite que pourrait donner justement
les syndicats de chercheurs de
professeurs alors il y aura bien entendu
des mouvements de mobilisation de la
part des syndicats dès la semaine
prochaine
et puis ensuite il va falloir mobiliser
aussi les élus et revoir comment on va
pouvoir changer ou faire évoluer cette
réforme du bon côté pour les chercheurs
et puis il ya ceux qui trouvent que oui
et puis il ya ceux qui trouvent que
cette réforme suffit les présidents
d'université mais elle est loin de
satisfaire les précaires et c'est eux
qui sont les premiers touchés
et évidemment le but d'une réforme
réussie serait de revaloriser réellement
les filières de faire de l'attractivité
pour les métiers de la recherche et de
garder nos talents puisque au jeu
du les chercheurs français
majoritairement partent à l'étranger là
où ils sont mieux payés là où ils ont un
horizon qui n'est pas le cas ce qui
n'est pas le cas en france
or la réforme favorise encore davantage
le mandarinat locale le recrutement
local sans compétence et c'est ça qui
fait peur aujourd'hui aux chercheurs et
bien ce sera le mois de la fin alexis
poulain merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci pour cet éclairage je
rappelle que vous êtes un de nos
éditorialistes ici chez arte france